ONE GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE GONNA
START THE CAMINO REVVING TAX WE
JUST GOT A QUORUM SO --
IS HIGHLY TO GROW.
BURKE [inaudible]
I'M SHEET THAT'S RIGHT TEAM LEFT
OKAY WILL START A SUBCOMMITTEE
THANK YOU SENATOR WOULD --
FILE ITEM ONE S. B. NINE FIFTY
ONE THE TO LIKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE WE'RE STILL IN FLOOR
SESSION SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR ACCOMMODATING MEDIA HERE SB
NINE FIVE ONE TODAY AND WELCOME
BACK FROM SUMMER BREAK MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF FOR
EVERYONE'S TIME WHEN THIS BILL
AND FOR AND FOR TODAY'S HEARING
NOT KEEP MY PIECE BRIEF.
AND WILL SPEAK TO THE MERITS OF
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE FILM AND
TELEVISION INDUSTRY CAME ONTO MY
MYSELF IN SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN ASKED THAT WE CARRY S. B..
NINE FIVE ONE TO REAUTHORIZE THE
CALIFORNIA FEEL.
AND I WAS PLEASED TO DO SO A
COORDINATED AND SUCCESSFUL
EFFORT WITH MAY BETWEEN MYSELF
YOUR COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON IN THE LEADERSHIP IN
BOTH HOUSES. TO GET THE PROGRAM
FUNDED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET AND
I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY THAT WE
WERE SUCCESSFUL IN DOING SO.
TODAY AS REFLECTED THE COMMITTEE
NOW SINCE I ASK THE COMMITTEE TO
REDUCE THE CONCEPT OF THE BILL
TO A SIMPLE EXTENSION.
OF THE ELLIOT REPORTING DEADLINE
FOR THE FILM TAX CREDIT FOR TWO
REASONS FIRST.
THE ALLEY ALSO REQUEST FOR
EXTENSION WAS RECEIVED AFTER THE
DEADLINE IN ORDER FOR IT TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET BILL
ACCORDINGLY WITH NO OBJECTION
FROM THE STAKEHOLDERS I'D LIKE
TO HONOR THAT REQUEST HERE.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT WITH
THE UPDATE REPORT DATE THE LA
OPEN INCLUDE ALL OF THE REPORTED
EXPENDITURES AS WELL AS DATA
FROM THE THREE POINT THE THREE
POINT OH PROGRAM.
JUST PROVIDE SOME CLARITY --
CURRENTLY --
THE ARE ANNUAL FUNDING FOR THE
TAX CREDIT TO POINT OUT THE
PROGRAM WE ARE JUST IN IN THE
FIVE YEAR PERIOD --
THE WAS THAT FUNDING THAT ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THE
CREDITS ALLOCATED SO FAR ARE
NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
MILLION.
AND SOLD THE ADDITIONAL EXPENSE
FROM THE TIME I WILL ALLOW US TO
CONTINUE TO COLLECT THIS DATA.
TO ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE TO
SPIN DOWN THOSE DOLLARS --
AND WILL BE PREPARED TO GO FOR
IT WITH THE TAX CREDIT THREE
POINT NOW.
AND MR WEATHERFORD DOWN IS HERE
FROM THE ALEJO WHO PLANS TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
THE SECOND REASON IS BECAUSE
THERE IS ONGOING --
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT --
SOME ADDITIONAL POTENTIALLY
TWEAK SUFFIXES WE MIGHT MAKE TO
THIS VERSION OF THE FILM TAX
CREDIT --
THE INDUSTRY'S MEETING WITH
OTHER KEY STAKEHOLDERS AND SO AS
A RESULT WE JUST WANT TO KEEP
THIS VEHICLE ALIVE AND MOVING IN
CASE.
EMPHASIS IN CASE THERE'S SOME
ADDITIONAL ADJUSTMENTS THAT THAT
KEY STAKEHOLDERS WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE TO THE TAX CREDIT WITH THAT
ARM ALL ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
ALLOWING US TO KEEP THE BILL
MOVING.
AND ATHLETES TO ALLOW THE LA
OTHER PROVIDE TEST.
FOR I'M SORRY CITING.
I DON'T HOLD ON ONE SECOND WE
HAVE A QUORUM AS I WOULD LIKE TO
GROW.
BURKE HERE.
GROWTH HERE.
CHIU.
GRAY THEIR MULLIN THIS MULLIN
QUIRK HERE.
REVERSE TING VOEPEL YOU
[inaudible]
F. QUARTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO HER.
AND BRING WITH THE FORD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST THE BILL.
HERE IS YOUR TITLE IS ALL THEY
NEED I'M.
WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF OKAY I
DON'T LOOK AT DOCTOR QUIRK.
ACTUALLY I GUESS RESPONSE ON
THAT WELL LET ME GET WITNESSES
THAT ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SPUR THEM GO UNANSWERED QUESTION
CENTER TITLE WAS.
PLENTY IF THAT'S OKAY WITH YOU.
GREAT ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MRS JOHNSON ON BEHALF
THE DIRECTORS GUILD OF AMERICA
IN STRONG SUPPORT LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
SHE INVESTMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS INSIDE AFTER IN
SUPPORT.
KAREN LAYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
MAYOR LONDON PARADE.
AND THE PASTA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS BUT THE SONGS
PARTAKE THINK YOU.
TERRY THOMAS SOMEDAY HAVE THE
MOTION PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF
AMERICAN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE WRATH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE COMMENTS AND
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DARK QUIRK.
THOUGHT YES SO.
I UNDERSTAND YOU WANT MORE TIME.
WHICH IS FINE BUT WHY THE
PARTICULAR DATE YOU CHAU --
YES EDITION OF YEARS OF OF
OBSERVATIONS WILL ALLOW US TO
REVIEW --
NEARLY MOST NEARLY ALL OF THE
PROGRAMS EVERY PROJECTS TO
REQUIRE THAT THE RECEIVE --
CREDITS THROUGH THAT A TO POINT
OUT PROGRAM AS WELL AS ALLOW US
TO COMMENT ON THE ADMINISTRATION
A THREE POINT OH PROGRAM --
THE THE DATE ITSELF ARM WAS
BASED ON TRYING TO PROVIDE.
SOME INFORMATION --
AHEAD OF YOU KNOW THE FUTURE
EFFORTS TO REAUTHORIZE OR YOU
KNOW DISCUSSIONS TO REAUTHORIZE
THE FILM TAX CREDIT.
AND WHAT DOES THE THREE POINT
KNOW ONE DOES IT TO EXPIRE --
THE THE PROGRAM IS REAUTHORIZE
THROUGH --
JULY.
WITH JUNE THIRTIETH.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE OKAY THANK
YOU YEAH I THINK THAT'S ABOUT
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
MISTER RIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND SARAH
GOT.
FIRST A COMMENT THAT YOU KNOW
I'VE GOT A HISTORY SUPPORTING.
THE TAX BILL.
ON AS RELATES TO THIS INDUSTRY
--
THAT PREDATES MY SERVICE
LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY WORKED ON
THIS LEGISLATION AYE AS A
STAFFER SOME MANY MANY TO GO
INSIDE APPRECIATION FOR TRYING
TO DO AND AND I'VE BEEN
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT AYE IN
ELECTED OFFICE.
I DO WANT TAKE A MOMENT TO JUST
COMMENT THOUGH.
ON WHEN.
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LOS
ANGELES IS EXPERIENCING A
CHALLENGES SUCH AS THE ONE THAT
FELL MINISTRY HAS.
A EXPERIENCE IN A LOT OF
RELOCATION IN AND OUT OF STATE
ACTIVITY AND A LOT OF THE ORIGIN
ORDER OR GENESIS.
WERE.
WE'VE SEEN THESE TAX CREDIT BILL
SO.
I EVERYBODY COMES RIGHT AND WE
ALL FIND RELIGION.
BUT WHEN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN
AGRICULTURE AND OTHER IMPORTANT
ISSUES IN THISSTATE A HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES SOMETIMES
THE CAVALRY FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA FAILS TO ARRIVE.
AND SO EYES WILL MAKE THAT
COMMENT BECAUSE I KNOW WE'RE
GONNA HAVE OP TASTE WORK
TOGETHER.
ON FUTURE LEGISLATION ISSUES AND
I HOPE THAT --
MAYBE YOU COULD BE A LEADER
SINCE I KNOW YOU'RE PASSIONATE.
IN HELPING US GET SUPPORT FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE IN ON IN
SUPPORT OF ALL OF OUR
INDUSTRIES.
AND KEEPING THEM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FILLED WITH THE GRAY OUT BE YOUR
FIRST PSYCHO THANK YOU SENATOR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR GREY THERE ARE PLENTY OF US
FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THAT
HAVE SUPPORTED THE CENTRAL
VALLEY I BEING ONE OF THEM.
I GOT TWO VOTES THAT --
SENATOR WHICH LATE BECAUSE I ASK
YOUR I HOPE THAT YOU VERY MUCH
FOR A BEGINNING MS HOW ANY
COLOR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THIS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE BURKE AYE BROUGH BRO I
CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY.
ON GRAY AYE MELINDA'S.
MULLIN QUIRK OUR BURKE AYE RIVAS
TING.
VOEPEL I AM.
THAT BILLS OUT.
AND WE'RE WAITING FOR A FEW MORE
TO COME AND PICK VERY MUCH
THINGS TIME I APPRECIATE MADAM
CHAIR MEDICAL.
THING
.
FILE ITEM.
ONE S. B. NINE FIFTY ONE AND THE
SOUND COOLEY ABSENTEE
[inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN I THE IDEA OF A SEAL
.
FILE ITEM ONE S. B. NINE FIFTY
ONE CALL THE ABSENTEES KING.
TING I THOUGHT FIT HERE
[inaudible]
WHERE TORRENT